ich bin dann einmal ein zitat zeigen von
jürgen klopp dem berühmten fußball coach
stellt sich nämlich heute zum impfen
geäußert
jürgen klopp sagt es ist wie betrunken
autofahren ich verstehe nicht warum das
eine einschränkung der freiheit ist wenn
es so ist dann ist das verbot betrunken
zu fahren auch eine
freiheitsbeschränkung vor schimke hat
herr klopp recht
also ich denke dass es gut und richtig
ist dass wir in deutschland keine
impfpflicht haben das sollte auch so
bleiben und ich bin auch der auffassung
dass wir alle maßnahmen die wir im
politischen ergreifen immer auch das
ziel verfolgen müssen den menschen
glaubhaft zu machen dass die
einschränkungen die wir vornehmen nur so
lange gelten wie sie erforderlich sind
und ich will an der stelle noch eines
sagen herrnsheimer wir haben im letzten
jahr eine reihe von zielmarken erfahren
im politischen wenn das passiert dann
machen wir das wenn wir das erreichen
dann machen wir das und was ist passiert
der lok ton wurde immer länger
fortgeführt die einschränkungen wurden
immer länger fortgeführt was ich
inzwischen sehe bei den menschen ist
einfach auch eine sinkende
glaubwürdigkeit aber das kommt mir echt
oder nicht
also ich kann mir nicht für freiheits
einschränkungen also ich kann klar also
hier antworten körper trägt aber bevor
ich hierzu also klopp hat einfach recht
das manchmal aber sie sagen wir hätten
gesagt werden dass und das ist dann
machen wir das und es ist dann nicht
passiert was wäre dafür ein beispiel
zum beispiel die frage wie lange ein
locker und geht zum beispiel die frage
wie lange müssen wir noch masken tragen
zum beispiel die frage wann machen die
schulen wieder auf aber sie hatte über
menschen wurden motiviert immer länger
durchzuhalten das lange immer länger
mitzumachen und dann wurden sie am ende
enttäuscht ich das also dass es gar dass
wir die maske noch tagen ist ja klar
aber ich habe mir das lange lauter
braucht ja bei den anteilen wie sie
nicht dass sie mich doch einfach die
phase die masken müsste was man sich
noch tragen weil wir die impfquoten ich
habe hat ja auch ein stör gerade gesagt
wenn wir jetzt die meisten wegnehmen in
den innenräumen hätten wir relativ
schnell so stark steigen aber ich finde
dass also wichtig dass man so etwas was
man sagt auch immer mit beispielen gut
belegen kann wo hätten wir denn gesagt
wenn das und das erreicht ist dann
nachher das wir hätten es da nicht getan
bei den bei den genannten beispielen
euro wohl immer wieder und immer wieder
hatten die menschen dann erfahren müssen
dass dieser zustand sich weiterhin fort
wo ich das noch länger zu gemerkt dass
ich mich auch so kompliziert aus ich
sage mal einfach bleiben wir doch bei
ihrem beispiel mit den masken teil wann
haben wir dann gesagt also wenn das und
das passiert ist dann müssen die masken
nicht mehr getragen werden und das wäre
dann passiert und wir hätten dann gesagt
jetzt müssen die meisten weitergetragen
woher das der fall gewesen ich möchte an
ein beispiel erinnern damals im jahr
2020 hieß es zuerst wenn wir eine wende
unter einer bestimmten incident sind
dann öffnen wir wieder das ist ein ganz
ganz konkretes beispiel dass ich noch
sehr lebendig in erinnerung habe und wir
haben trotzdem weiter geschlossen gehabt
dann hieß es irgendwann nach etlichen
monaten wenn wir wenn die todeszahlen
unter eine bestimmte marke rücken dann
können wir wieder mehr freiheit zu
lassen und immer ist es nicht passiert
und das will ich sagen die enttäuschung
die sich da eben auch breit macht und
diese desillusion auch in der
bevölkerung führt natürlich dazu dass
man das alles nicht mehr ernst nimmt
weil man das nicht mehr glaubt er und
das führt dazu dass die menschen sich
auch an entsprechende regelungen gar
nicht mehr herunterladen es gab ja die
äußerung dass wenn alle ein impfangebot
erhalten haben dass dann alle
einschränkungen fallen soll wer hätte
das hier gesagt das wurde aus der
regierung immer wieder so kommunizieren
ich etwas lernen dass wir dass wir sagen
also wenn jeder ein impfangebot hat dass
wir dann alles eröffnen werde das hier
gesagt das würde ja bedeuten also man
muss ja die sein name ist hase ich achte
auf solche dinge sehr genau in dem sinne
stellen wir uns jetzt mal vor es hätten
sich nur 40 prozent der leute impfen
lassen werden also an ebenfalls gebot
gemacht 40 leute hätten zugegriffen da
hätten wir doch nie gesagt wir werden
das jetzt alles da wären doch aus ich
weiß nicht wie viele menschen anlass
immer die pandemie ist zu ende wenn wir
einen impfstoff haben das habe ich auch
nie gesagt dass ich bei 8 auf set immer
ganz genau ich so ein satz wird kein
vernünftiger wissenschaft da wird einer
stimme also schon sagen sagen war ich ja
gar nicht war es wie stark der impfstoff
wirkt also wenn ich hier sage neben
stoff habe wir mussten am anfang hatten
wir mit einem impfstoff gerechnet wir
hatten damit gerechnet dass der beste
impfstoff eine wirkung ungefähr 60
prozent hat und daher niemand wäre auf
die idee gekommen zu sagen werden wir
neben stoff haben 60 prozent wirkung das
dann außerdem plant seine ist somit also
man muss vorsichtig sein war so etwas
sagt sich immer schnell ich will dort
ist gebrochen worden werden dann
konkreter wird also was ist ein lassen
uns konkret bleiben ich wollte von ihnen
wissen dass die tat von jürgen klopp
sich nicht impfen lassen ist wie
betrunken auto fahren sie sagen er hat
recht ja ganz er sagt das bedeutet ja am
ende dass derjenige der sich nicht
impfen lässt
eine straftat begeht betrogen autofahren
an einen bestimmten promille-wert ist
eine straftat also zunächst damals
bedeutet nicht dass er nicht trinken
darf denn also ich darf mich betrinken
könnt was jetzt zum beispiel also hier
in der sendung tun aber ich darf dann
nicht auto fahren und so ist es auch
wenn ich jetzt mal deswegen also
komplett und games bin und gehe in eine
situation hinein wo eigentlich zweig ist
ich täusche vor dass ich gehe ist wenn
dann gefährlich andere und also ich
glaube dass solche beispiele haben klopp
den ich sehr schätze hier also folgen
gewesen sind und also somit ist das also
ich gefährde ja nicht nur mich selbst es
gibt ja jetzt leute zum beispiel die die
eben pässe fälschen die sind gar nicht
geimpft die
gesellschaft rein und sagen okay alles
wunderbar ich bin jetzt da die gefährden
aber sich und andere
[Musik]